[Music]
welcome back everyone
i hope you have had some great
interactions with my colleagues
in exhibit booth now i would like to
invite our next speaker
dr tomozy mashimo from institute of
medical sciences
university of tokyo japan he is the
director of
laboratory animal research center topic
of his talk
is rapid and accurate detection of novel
coronavirus
sars curve 2 using crispr cash 3.
over to you dr tamoji mashimo
first of all i'd like to thank the
organizer for
giving me this opportunity especially in
this critical condition
of code 19 here in japan
this year april actually i have moved to
the university of tokyo
institute of medical science from osaka
university
then faced this difficult situation
so today i'd like to talk about crispr
tools for genome editing
as well as for new diagnostic tool for
copy 19
that we have recently developed using
crispr casserole system
in this first slide i like to confirm my
coi
i'm a co-founder and now scientific
advisor for c4u startup company
here in japan
first episode in my talk is crispr
cassie system
is useful for germ editing in eukaryotic
cells
as you know crispr casino is widely used
as a gene editing tool
all over the world but it is just one
in a wide variety of many crispr cast
system for example
there are several cast proteins from
casserole to class 14
which are classified into two classes
class 1
and class 2. they are further divided
into three different types from type 1
type 3 type 4 in class 1
and type 2 type 5 type 6
in class 2. what are the difference
between the two classes
the main difference is the number of the
effector molecules
classifying factors contain multiple
subunits as you see here
class two affected as single known
singularized proteins like casino and
castor and cassating
casanong as you know belong to class 2
type 2 system
and class a gas 12 also we call
cpf1 is type 5 system for dna
cassatin type 6 system enables the rna
editing
which are different from the cas9 and
cast of dna editing
so far class 2 system casino cluster at
casa tin have been used for genome
editing
then we had a question can we use
classroom
crispr system as a genuine editing tool
the answer is yes we can
class one type 1 crispr system we called
crispr class 3
system contains 6 gas proteins cas5
class 6 k7 gas 8 gas 11
those 5 cast protein complex complex
called
cascade cassery
has a strong dna nucleus and helicase
activity
that could genera degradate
fast phase plasmid dnase
cascades contain guide rna or called
crispr rna
shown in yellow line that recognize
target sequences
the different features between cas9 and
cassie system for
general editing are severals as you can
see here
the crisper casserole induces large
deletions
upstream of the target sequences
the deletion size ranging from several
hundred to thousand base pair you can
see
degraded pcr product pressure band on
other cell here
and you can also see several hundred two
thousand deletions
but here upstream of the target site
as shown in lead line
therefore the cassery is more applicable
to delete
large lesions or knockout for genomic
region
on the other hand cas9 generally used
for
genetic generating small intermutation
another feature of cassery is crispr rna
recognized recognition size
which is totally 27 nucleotide
longer than 20 nucleotides of cas9 guide
rna
so we hypothesize this longer
recognition of
gas3 crispr rna may induce more
specificity
of gamma editing
in this slide we compare the two systems
k3
and cas9 in the same experimental
conditions for evaluating the off-target
effects
we identified both k3 and cas9
mediated on target mutations as you can
see
in red dot
however we only identified off-target
mutations
induced by kas9 here in blue dots
but not of target mutations observed by
cast 3
genome editing
we can also find various small
intermutations by
crispr cast 9 here you can see
so type 1 e crispr showed comparable
or lower of target activity compared
with crystal cast 9.
in this slide we have tried a functional
general queen
using crystal castry systems
we used strona plus vector including
ef alpha promoters and
pyrogen cassette with one cloves
homology
arms at both ends
and we transfer those drona plasmid into
the hex
293 human cells
with the crisper cast three systems
as you see both crisper castry and cas9
system can
induce efficient gene knock in at the
target site by homologous recombinations
finally collaborating with hota sensei
and okuzak sensei at ips center in kyoto
university
we showed exon skipping of the decent
muscular dystrophy gene using crispr
castor system
as an example of potential therapeutic
applications
we compare the efficiency of kasana in
mediated exon skipping
using two guide rna as here
blue bars or cassie mediated exon
skipping
as shown in red bars here
we found that even a single crispr rna
with cast three
transcript drastically increases the
exon skipping efficiency
as shown here red bus compared to the
dual guide rna
casino system as shown here bluebird
because cassary could mediate large
deletions
of the genomic region including the four
exons
here
we also confirmed the recovery of dmd
expression dmg the gene expression
in the patient-derived ips cells
as you can see here messenger rna levels
by rtpcr and protein levels
in western protein gels the crispr class
3 recover
dmd expression in patient-derived ips
ips cells
here is the summary a characteristic for
cassery and casino mediated genome
editing
cassery has a strong helicase and
nucleus activity
which can easily induce a broad dna
degradation
like unique directional rise
deletion at the target site
therefore it may be used for complete
functional genocide
are for for excluding the large genomic
regions such as promoter regions
enhancer regions and repeat sequences
the importance for the industrial
companies is a patent issues
i think it might be more clear for
crispr cassie compared to the gas
9.
here in episode 2 i would like to talk
about crispr-based
diagnostic tools castrel cassatine
and class 3.
as you know jennifer's group and fans
group have harnessed
cast web and casting scarcity
respectfully to make crisp based
diagnostic tools
they have started the venture company
mamos bioscience
and shark bioscience and successfully
developed rapid nucleic acid detection
system
called detector with gastroware
and sherlock with gasatin
they actually used unique feature of the
crisper cast enzyme
this is both cartridge and cassadine
enzyme but not casino enzyme
exhibit non-specific and nuclear
activity in trans after genome editing
at the target site in cis
using this collateral single-strand dna
previous activity
they developed easy and rapid dissection
system of virus infections such as
copit19
so my question is how about cassery
systems
here you can see the crisper casserole
system has all
has also collaterally ssdna cleavage
activities
when we mix cascade cascari
to a double sun dna that is the target
double standard dna fragment
and donor dna that is either
linear single strand dna more than one
kilobase or
sakura m13 single stranded dna
we observed the single strand dna
cleavage for both dna
if the target sequence perfectly matched
with the target
double sun dna and gas 3 was activated
you see here dna degradation
on the agarose cell by led bulbs
this is a representative protocol for
sas cop2
detection including four steps
first step is a conventional rna
extraction
second step is rt lamp for dna
amplification step this just needs
20 to 30 minutes
third step is cassie based nucleic acid
detection
in 10 minutes and lastly
lateral flow essay in 2 minutes
totally 14-40 minutes we can detect
cellscop2 virus with excellent
sensitivity and high specificity
as compared to rtp shell-based common
corbit 19 assay
therefore we named this protocol
operated nucleic acid detection assay as
kona
konan used a lateral fluid as a test
strip
which is generally used for portable
antigen system like
influenza virus detection as you can see
here
conan can detect rapid resusci virus
without infection of subscribe
you'd see lower negative bond here
if you infect it you'll see a positive
bond
in the upper side here
for those datas we have already
deported a preprint at net archive
you can read it on the website
and released from the homepage of the
university of tokyo here you can see
if you are interested in our technology
using crystal castle systems for genome
editing
and crisp firebase diagnostics please
contact
startup company c4u
here is the website
so thank you very much for your
attentions and i'm very glad to have
your questions
thank you dr bashimo for sharing
exciting approach
of using crispr cash 3 for kovid19
detection